all right Sean and Jose yes yes Sean
Jose you guys grew up where you're
you're both from L.A originally yeah
we're from L.A you guys are friends yeah
you grew up yeah I know it's we're
little yeah and uh tell me about your
families growing up
um my dad is though they've been
together you know uh but I have older
brothers that used to you know go take
me to Figueroa and holler at girls since
I was little so I learned I learned that
myself you saw when you were a kid yeah
you know my brothers used to take me so
I I I started to say it started I used
to pass the figure out early in the
morning before I go to work it is a
morning season I was like Temptations
Temptation until like how old are you
now I'm 30 they're 30. so Figaro was was
that active like that just yeah I'm
talking about once I was 20 man like
yeah yeah he is I was 20 but I started
doing it like 22 23 when uh when I got a
little bit of Boston I started putting
them in the truck you know what I'm
talking about right you remember your
first time yeah it was a little bit of
light skinny um black girl she was so
beautiful here I remember yeah some of
the girls down there are still talking
about like a describer is probably one
of the models of being the shows the you
know the hip-hop shows yeah yeah they're
it's unlike any other city I think yeah
yeah but a nice bodies you you see here
they're just in the thong bro I'm like
it's crazy stuff like that man yeah and
Jose you uh you've been doing this for
how long uh about maybe about six seven
years
but you know it's just not all of them
are are can I tell you um not all of
them are
some of them would you know will play
games also too you know yeah for sure
kids free money or whatnot you know
they're Hustlers yeah they are made that
happen to me before it's like uh robbed
yeah no yeah you could say Rob maybe go
to a restaurant come out gone you know
with all this stuff with the phone in
there yeah it happened
but I mean not all of them are the same
some are you know good and
you know happy ending like they say yeah
yeah have you guys had relationships
with women that are not from
that are not sex workers
did we if we had yeah yeah the ones in
the hotels and stuff like that nobody
regular girlfriend oh yeah yeah yeah
and what do you prefer do you prefer
prefer these kind of relationships with
these girls to be honest is
I hate those girls the 30 minutes only
they take your 60 80 bucks quick you
want to hang out I want to hang out like
for two three hours
Maggie yeah
you uh are drugs a part of your guy's
life
I used to some sometimes I think
Figueroa Street and drugs kind of go
hand in hand well but you can find it
easy there
yeah but the girls are into it the guys
it seems like a lot of the tricks are
into it too yeah but yeah they want to
be but they got to be on drugs right
it's cold as [__] it's they're on
tongues it's just a little big Keys you
know they do be out there at five four
in the morning early you guys go before
you go to work or after well I used to
do almost early in the morning one time
I caught him
what's up
the streets that was the most surprising
thing I learned about Figaro Street is
that like four to five a.m is one of the
busiest
like 15 cars on on the little streets
just checking them out going around like
this why do you think that is is the
guys they're like they're sneaking away
from their wives yeah
there's a lot of guys you just like to
go talk [__] to the holes and stuff like
that yeah a lot of the guys are just
cruising around yeah he's just across
the street they're not really picking up
anybody because they're almost they're
almost half it half naked
honestly a lot of these guys just passed
by just to look at them I guess I was
wondering what it's like for the people
who live on those streets
they're like normal people like
on the street with a BC Street I figurer
and they live there still live there
they're like whatever nobody's like you
get these almost naked women that are
beautiful
young yeah
it's crazy yeah it's crazy and the cops
just let it all roll them yeah well they
stopped one one or two just to make this
just to make it seem like they're doing
the job but it's all you know they give
tickets tickets for making money do you
think prostitution should be legalized
uh yesterday like Las Vegas yeah I think
you should be
Las Vegas is legal you you you see the
handbook something but you you could
pick what you want you College you go
see your room yeah yeah as long as
professionally protection and all that
you know how often do you go down there
Jose
um at least
twice a week twice in one week maybe
maybe depends depends on my money it
depends on the money you guys yeah me
too yeah and same with you yeah but see
if I have money I'll go three four times
a week but you know it's not like that
you know it's just amazing so one or two
and then I already got the ones I like
so you know are there certain girls that
you yeah but I go look for them I don't
lose I like them like skinny you know
Mexican shorts what's your I mean
there's many different types you know
every shapes and size and colors yeah
but I just like I'm skinny and big booty
man it's just to me smacking do you guys
ever pick up the same girl I don't know
how I don't know we haven't got together
but we probably had because I'm not at
the same time
I see the girls they change up but I
mean most likely probably we have
probably half most you guys have been
down there enough that yeah maybe yeah I
think so so at some point you probably
messed around with the same girl yeah
probably probably yeah if you like a
short and thick and light skin yeah yeah
he did is that how you like them unless
I like it yeah they're pretty nice and
and black girls no like Mexican girls
Mexican girls or white girls
you hardly see uh Chinese girls over
there yeah yeah you can you see one or
two yeah very few very few yeah
there's pimps that are involved in this
does that ever become a problem for you
guys not really because of those issues
we don't okay because the girls ask for
before
you pretend like they don't have a pimp
yeah
but nowadays the a lot of girls work by
themselves yeah a lot of girls but I
think they work by themselves now
because of
not all girls are just dedicated to that
I guess they just might have a job and
just go there for
maybe they need money yeah there are
girls that have you know
make some extra money but I guess
probably the other girls that do happen
is my my tell them you know get out the
way or leave or who knows I don't know
how that works but
I know there's girls like Independence
and
they don't necessarily have pimps but
yeah there is pimps I know there's pimps
yeah might not there but maybe in the
corner dangerous neighborhood girls get
you know people get shot and killed all
the time yeah
I mean I mean there's nice looking girls
tell you that yeah have you ever
developed feelings for any of these
girls at you well I I say like in one of
the lockers but uh you know I hate this
year the shoes get picked up quick
before before when I busted you already
she's already getting picked up man like
and I'm like [__] man I gotta wait 30
minutes or get another one or something
like that
yeah the Personality yeah some of them
won't even get on it they see you know
they won't they won't get in the car
because they know you won't come oh you
know they hate it say it again I'm sorry
they know you you can't you can't come
quick so they know you're drugged up
you're gonna beat beat the [__] up like
you know so they they look for the the
drunk ones they look for the ones that
are gonna take the money quick
oh is that right that's how they do it
wow like imagine if I'm I'll drug Dublin
and and they see my face oh he's no he's
he's drug he's being dubbed no they're
they're trying to get another one you
know everything she's so cute she'll
pick up anytime you know
but like the little fat ones or the ugly
ones they they take anything you know
have you you guys been married before
um no I was with a girlfriend but that
number
and did the figaroid Temptation never
get in the world
I used to go when I was I used to go and
I had a girl you know just in the
mornings but it's nothing usual
like I said I cheated because I was not
with her she separated so I started
doing it I started doing it so when you
were in that relationship you you were
not going to fix no no I used to just
pass it but I never got I never made I
never never picked anyone up never
picked one up but I she you won a day
she'll come and grab my boss and I'm
like
like you know yeah they do that are you
the police are you a police yeah yeah
the way they check that you're not a cop
is by yeah touching your drunk yeah
and Jose you've you've had relationships
with with girls that are not on the
street yeah yeah yeah definitely yeah
what do you prefer that a committed it
all depends like sometimes you know you
get to the argument with your with your
girl whatever you know find a way to
slide out there let's go not to make an
excuse just to go over there but yeah I
mean I've done it before made an excuse
and just to slide over there
you know
what's your kind of girl
I mean
John likes the uh I mean the short
skinny ones yeah big buzz you know
that's just the main thing nothing no I
really I really don't like messing
around with black girls but I mean I
don't have nothing against them or
nothing but it just it's just I just
like Mexicans or a lot of Mexicans I've
learned uh like black girls though yeah
I mean they got big lips they could take
care of whatever you you provide them
they'll take it all in
yeah
and do you uh
how much I mean you're spending a lot of
your income on yeah you could say yeah
like I make 600 a week 200 girls
it depends on my when I'm in the mood
like Fair Friday Saturday I put like
200. but it only depends you get like
81. it all depends man how you work
yeah I mean if you know them they might
get you a little deal or something maybe
you know been with them before yeah like
they know you're ready he's good he'll
come and quit he'll come quick
you ever get arrested
not for that is that even a concern
we're always on the lookout because I
don't want to get caught for that I
don't know my record be like that but
hey
it is what it is yeah it's a playground
isn't it yeah it is yeah they catch
literally goes 20 24 hours every day of
the week every day of the week you go
down there Sunday you think everyone's
going to church you'll see one or two
three there but five in the morning is
the it's four in the morning that's the
four or five in the morning is the best
time you pick something good man it'd be
crazy because they all done yeah like
this time of year it's cold in the
morning young too young I mean nice
looking girls
yeah it's a crazy lifestyle down there
you guys live nearby
yes I live uh
Figueroa like Imperial or something like
that yeah so you're in the neighborhood
yeah yeah so so the temptation's always
there yeah someone's there they go to
the storehouse so I was there walking
distance
not that far
if you had more money would you go more
often
did you could say yes no no yeah yes
yeah if I'm single like if you know it
all depends man uh but yeah if I see you
I've seen how I like them I'll be there
every day you see a new one then you're
there yeah
you haven't seen that one we're getting
a little short right here with a blonde
hair yeah oh yeah it's already heavier
it was still like that I got a number do
you think humans were meant to be
uh monogamous you know just a
relationship with one person nah I had
like three four man
that's that's a Temptation
dogs so being in a marriage or a
committed relationship is just you feel
trapped yeah yeah yeah it might be a
single message you could be doing
whatever you want stick it here stick it
over there stick it here you know
I'm a commitment while you can
you have any crazy stories of things
you've been through
one girl
we have a threesome with her she she was
doing too much man she was she first she
was not liking it and then she she was
paying us to keep [__] her
that was a crazy night we we pay the
first and then she was trying to pay us
so we could keep [__] I had to go to
work so I left it
I was like Mama Jesus I gotta go to work
man I gotta lose my job
where do you guys typically go you go to
a motel room yeah yeah hotel we try to
pay the hourly you know it took three
hours sometimes sometimes they have
their own room 40 40 40 for two hours or
depends 45 that you want to live a
better one 65 for two hours or something
like that
you can do what you need to do you guys
always you're always using a condom yeah
yeah yeah yeah
they they the girls too yeah some girls
they don't they they're strictly
professionally they they yeah they do
that that's the I guess professional
jobs for them they maintain clean they
wash up
protection wash up real quick with a
wiping and go to get another one yeah
it's crazy
what would you say you've learned from
your your time down on Figueroa Street
nothing
um not to get too attached to them
because you lose money man
you know learn how to hold on control
yourself man or get a girl that's gonna
be giving it to you or
or or
keep paying your money lose your money
yeah you got to learn how to give
feelings also not here why it's failing
to get too attached to that you know
because I mean I've seen people
that actually will go on other no other
people are going actually start getting
feelings for that
for that one person and
it's not good
yeah all right John and Jose thank you
so much for sharing your stories thank
you thank you man have fun this weekend
yes
all right you guys thank you very much
thank you